moindre des choses pour la france qui a
déclaré la guerre à l'islam is y compris
en allant au mali parce que défendre le
mali quand il s'est mis c'est aussi
défendre la france je vois pas la
différence avec l'arménie lorsqu'elle
est attaquée par des islamistes arrivés
aux côtés de l'armée azérie grâce à la
turquie
[Musique]
m
la france a donné l'impression
effectivement d'abandonner arménie de
fait jean yves le drian ministre des
affaires étrangères a donné l'impression
que dans le conflit de l'automne dernier
tout se valaient les arts et les airs et
les arméniens se taper entre eux et on
n'avait pas à prendre partie ce qui
était scandaleux puisqu'il y avait
vraiment un agresseur il y avait un pays
qui utilisaient des mercenaires
djihadistes qui utilisait des bombes au
phosphore tiré sur des civils macro lui
pneus suivez pas tellement cette ligne
effectivement ils donnaient l'impression
que quitte être en porte à faux avec son
mini se manifestait officiellement ou
officieusement son soutien au peuple
arménien même si ce n'était pas assez
mais c'était passé pourquoi parce que
l'arménie dans une région sous influence
à la fois russe et turc la russie est un
peu considéré comme une ennemie
géopolitique depuis des années on va pas
rajouter un sujet de conflit la turquie
qui a soutenu l'azerbaïdjan dingue et
appartient à l'otan donc c'est compliqué
parce qu'on se met à dos les américains
l'allemagne qui fait partie de l'union
européenne mais bien une grosse minorité
turque donc ne voulait pas se mettre à
dos erdogan lors ce conflit avait plein
de raisons pour que la france ne se
manifeste pas trop en faveur de
l'arménie même si je pense que la
plupart des français sont en faveur de
l'arménie et pas seulement parce qu'elle
est la victime mais pour des raisons
historiques et presque morale on a eu de
grands de grands arméniens qui sont
devenus des citoyens français plus
français que les français c'est le plus
vieux pays chrétien 300 après
jésus-christ donc chrétiens avant que
nous-mêmes français ou goulois soyons
réellement converti au christianisme
coût de richesses naturelles qui n'a pas
d'accès à la mer qui n'est riche surtout
que de l'argent que lui envoie sa
diaspora mais qui est un pays qui
effectivement vit entourée de pays et
demi lorsque vous avez un voisin qui
s'appelle la turquie qui soutient
l'azerbaïdjan et que le chef de ce pays
qui s'appelle erdogan appelle les
arméniens les restes de l'épée
sous-entendu ce qui reste de l'épée de
l'islam qui a décapité un million cinq
cent mille arméniens pendant le génocide
dont vous avez alief donc il va ça le
erdogan qui effectivement dit que le sud
de l'arménie taz eric il va aller jusqu
à yerevan ya de quoi être inquiet quand
on est un petit pays encore une fois de
trois millions d'habitants face aux 8 ou
9 million d'azéris et aux dizaines et
dizaines de millions je crois que 80
millions de la turquie tous les jours
tous les jours tous les jours les azéri
provoquent des incidents de frontière
plusieurs milliers de soldats série qui
sont sur le territoire de l'armee n'en
parle plus du karabakh halle depuis le
mois de mai laissant penser que il irait
plus loin puisque personne n'intervient
les gens commencent à partir en dix ans
mais de toute façon on est sous la
menace permanente c'est invivable et il
commence à songer à s'exiler non
seulement il rêva mais même à l'étranger
les armissanais recompose un bouchon
dans ce corridor corinne war turcs ou
turcique qui part de istanbul et qui va
jusqu'aux jusqu'à au groupe sea hawk si
niang en chine vous avez un territoire
occupé par les turcs
dans toute sa longueur toutes ces
populations par le turc erdogan est un
petit peu le chef de file de cette
population peut mettre beaucoup beaucoup
d'infrastructures qui permet de relier
tous les peuples turcique les uns avec
les autres et devenir une puissance
économique
démographique et politique plusieurs
centaines de millions d'habitants
la moindre des choses pour la france qui
a déclaré la guerre à l'islamisme y
compris en allant au mali parce que
défendre le mali contre les amis c'est
aussi défendre la france je vois pas la
différence avec l'arménie lorsqu'elle
est attaquée par des islamistes arrivés
aux côtés de l'armée azérie grâce à la
turquie ça nous concerne parce que la
turquie fait partie de la même alliance
militaire que nous qu'est l'otan et
quand vous avez un membre de votre
agence militaire qui se comporte de
manière agressive contre nous lorsqu'ils
traitent emmanuel macron de grosso modo
de malade mental d'hystérie couffé plus
quoi quand ils attaquent de manière la
grèce quand il menace des bateaux
français il ya quand même en bonne et il
faut signer la fin de la récréation on
pourrait venir sur place constater dans
le cadre du groupe de minsk qui est
chargée depuis 1993 94 de maintenir des
relations pacifiques entre l'azerbaïdjan
et l'arménie dans un cadre unilatérale
on pourrait envoyer des émissaires des
observateurs constater que effectivement
le territoire arménien a été envahi
formuler une
condamnation diplomatiquement sans aller
jusqu'aux conflits il ya quand même un
moyen au nom du droit interne seuls au
nom du traité de cessez-le-feu de
novembre 2020 lorsque jean yves le drian
tous les jours fait un point presse pour
un jour signalé qu il se passe des
choses là bas rien du tout c'est ça qui
à la fois injuste rageant
triste et déplorable
[Musique]